i uh i
for better or worse from.net rocks we
got involved with nbc
literally from the very first show which
was not in downtown oslo
uh so i met jacob a couple of years in
when he started getting started working
for the conference and became a partner
and and has been a part of it ever since
so for predator worse i've been doing
conferences for a really long time and
it's good to see a bunch of different
shows so if you ever run across me
before my name is richard campbell i
make podcasts and a bunch of other stuff
you can usually find me on twitter i
wrote my first line of code in 1977
which is not the most important thing to
happen in 1977 the most important thing
that happened in 1977 is star wars right
focus on priorities of course that
computers were a little bit different
back then
my first machine was a trs-80 model one
it had 4k of ram a cassette tape player
to store programs on
the
the graphical screen resolution was 127
by 47
and it had a version of basic not made
by microsoft it was actually a tiny
basic because it was only 4k ram and
that tiny basic had three error messages
what
how
and sorry
divide one by zero sorry
i think it's the best error message
going really i mean
what is object not found but sorry
uh and i make a lot of podcasts so my
friend carl franklin started dot net
rocks back in 2002 the 20th anniversary
of dot-net rocks will be this august
and on this stage tomorrow
we will record episode 1800
so i hope you'll come for that we've got
heather downing as our guest so we're
going to have some fun with it but the
zero zero shows are astonishing i did
not start with carl at the very
beginning i came on later i was
a guest in the first hundred and i we
became co-host as of episode 100. so now
we're at 1800 so i mean i run around for
a while
but
not didn't go from the beginning i also
make an i.t related podcast called run
as radio just exercising the other half
of my brain
and i'll talk a little bit about this in
the history too but that tablet show was
an interval for us
because we made a show called dotnet
rocks and there was a time around 2011
when i weren't so sure if.net rocked so
this was our backup show
it's been a long road friends
you know i'm talking about 20 years of
history now and it shocks me to assemble
that storyline and realize all the
things i've seen and been through and
you know even before that you know if
you look at hardware from 2002
you know the big innovation on the pc
side was we actually had black cases not
beige cases right that we'd made
progress at that point
although hdmi still really wasn't the
thing those were vga displays and dvi
displays back then but even then
apple made the most gorgeous machines
this g4
that came out in 2002 it was a power pc
based machine so which they would
eventually move away from but at the
time
it was just so much nicer than anybody
else and the top selling phone in 2002
was the nokia 1200
so and this you know i had one of the
variants of this this is back when you
got your text messages one of the time
right you literally had to say oh i have
a text message read text message show
you the text you could choose to reply
to it or delete it then it would show
you the next message
so i wrote
a script for some server management
software that would actually i'd gotten
an access to the api through the telco
to send me a text message when the
server had a problem
anyway i had a bug
32 767 text messages later
one at a time one at a time
so when i realize what i've done i call
the telco right and you get your tier
one tech support they ask me if i'll
turn it off and turn it back on again
like that kind of thing pretty quickly
scare that person they put me up to tier
two tier two is now frustrating
confusing me finally puts me through
tier three i've now been on the phone
for half an hour i get to tier three it
says hi my phone number is the other day
that and the guy says oh it's you
yeah this is that's a lot of text
messages you know they're 50 cents each
right i'm like
yeah
i'm more worried about deleting about
this i'll do this on my end you'll have
to delete one don't do that again
before rate limited apis you know not
the thing
we're getting i mean the hardware is
interesting but also to remember that in
2002 the dot-com bubble had just burst
so we had had the internet had gone to
become a publicly visible entity been
around since the 1970s but now it was a
public entity in 1995 and that kicked
off this insanity uh that spent a
tremendous amount of money and it all
slammed to a stop by 2002
for better or worse
right it was a big shake-up we we sort
of had to restructure and so priorities
were shifting around every time you have
a bubble like this a lot of money gets
spent much of it unwisely and now you
sort of come you have to back off and
rethink it and we're kind of in one of
those periods right now
uh just the pandemic has squeezed a
bunch of things most of us were pretty
busy through this but now you're
starting to see some more focus on
return investment and value
this was what was happening in 2002 as
well
there was google
but google was not the most popular
search engine
google was number three in 2002.
who was number two any guesses
it was yahoo
which really begs the question
who the heck was number one in 2002
it was msn search why why was msn search
the number one search engine
in 2002
ie6
ie6 had only come out the year before it
was with xp and xp represented the most
dominant operating system on the planet
nobody knew at the time because it was
only downhill from here for windows
right but xp was 90 plus percent
and most people barely under they
thought the internet was that little e
icon
right my internet's not working
right and their address bar had been
replaced by something
uh but yeah and they didn't know about
search you just typed into the address
bar and that defaulted msn search and so
msn search dominated not for much longer
you know by a couple of years google
will take it over and has kept it ever
since
but again different time
the beginning of 2002 bill gates
published an internal letter to
microsoft called trustworthy computing
because 2001 had been the anaconda cova
virus and nymda1 and sql slammer and all
these exploits that were all i mean they
were actually kind of fun hacks because
they were just propagators
you know 20 years on we live in a far
more weaponized world
in
uh
on the internet
but this was the beginning of microsoft
taking security very seriously this is
what kicks off what will become
xp service pack 2
and all the problems that will create
but also
microsoft building what i would argue is
still the definitive security team on
the internet
i don't think they're as good as they
were a few years ago they're kind of a
little sloppy these days but the
practice of actually taking internet
security seriously
starts here in a lot of respects with
bill's memo i would also point out bill
is not ceo at this point
he stepped down in 2000.
so this entire
20 years i'm talking about bill is not
the leader at microsoft he's the chief
architect for a few years then he goes
off to cure malaria and now he's sort of
around again but a different role
and of course if you come from the
dot-net world you know that 2002 was
when we got the first version of net in
february so that was c sharp one because
they weren't allowed to make java
anymore
uh and also
uh
they're the whole pitch of visual
studio.net at this time there'd been two
versions of studio before this that were
one the first one was called named 97
and the second one was name six because
numbers are hard
and now it was called.net
and at the time java was
any platform one language and so
microsoft's pitchfor.net was
22 languages one platform
try and name 22 languages from 2002
there was an eiffel.net
and an ocam.net
as well as the ones you know the c
sharps the vbs and so forth this before
f sharp shaft sharp will come later but
you know that's the beginning of the
move on.net and of course we got active
server pages the asp.net version which
was really a tool built for windows
developers to learn how to build web
pages
by not building web pages
all right by concealing everything that
was webby from you
it was very productive
but as a number of users went up issues
emerged
and so you know we drove a whole lot of
people there uh this the last sort of
death throes of netscape are happening
and it from becomes the mozilla
foundation and the first version of
firefox comes out now
and it will grow it'll be a very
successful browser it'll peak around
2009 which is around the time that
chrome shows up so this is before chrome
you know people are using ie for a
reason
the first version of safari won't show
up till the next year 2003 you'll you'll
have safari on the mac because we're
before all of those things
so we're doing client server development
primarily.net is very young so it's not
very robust it's leaking a fair bit of
memory and so forth as long as it's a
desktop app you're building and you can
reboot regularly you're good
but
microsoft in their efforts to
cooperate with the us government their
consent decree are being more public
more open around making software and so
one of the things they do is they
publish ecmas specifications for c-sharp
and for the runtime
and a young man by the name of miguel
diaz back in 2002 this is actually a
picture from the conference
in 2001
where he announced the mono project
see miguel had been working on ides for
linux for a long time and now he read
through the specifications this is a
pretty cool language i like this and so
he gathered up some friends open source
project to build an implementation
of.net will run on linux which is the
mono project it'll take him a few years
to get to the first version of 2004 when
the first bits are sort of out there
very much equivalent of dotnet 1.1 and
he puts himself in this insane world
where
the microsoft people are very leery of
him because
he's a linux guy
right and steve baumer told us linux is
a cancer
uh and the ladies people are all looking
at them like i know about that guy he
makes works with microsoft stuff that's
weird so
it was kind of an everybody hates miguel
era
but
he becomes incredibly important in this
story over time because the world's
still evolving right we this these early
few years we're trying to get to
interoperability we're trying to work
between different environments
this is where the ws star standards
start to emerge and we're looking for a
better way to do web development and
because web development's pretty rough
at that time you know
dreamweaver was the highlight but you
also needed front page extensions and
that's not great
and that's when david
heinemann
hanson
first came out with rails so he took the
language ruby which had been around for
years and was an interesting dynamic
language but he added in the scaffolding
engine pointed at a database scaffolds
initial architecture he can iterate
really rapidly and combined with a
dynamic language very fun development
environment and it takes off like a shot
but it also is a demonstration of the
power of open source at the time
again just before github and all those
sorts of things you know this is on
sourceforge
but it's
easy for people to make improvements to
it a bunch of contributors working
together to make better and better
software
and
that's interesting we're seeing a
different layer of what the internet can
do for us you know the dot-com boom had
been this initial hay on the internet
nobody knows you're a dog right you can
you can interact with anyone you can
share information quickly you can
distribute software relatively
efficiently as long as it's small
because dial up
but here we were starting to see the
first real signs of collaboration and
code
and it's one of the things that
accelerated rails was its ability for us
to share ideas in code with each other
we still need a long way to go but
this is where it begins and starts to
change the way we as developers work
the first iteration of amazon web
services actually goes all the way back
to 2002 and amazon's goal
at that time was to allow third-party
vendors to sell on the amazon site and
they wanted them to pay for the
infrastructure they were going to run on
it was all the way to squeeze more money
out of vendors
and this is amazon that's what they do
but 2006 they're doing the third restart
of it and it has s3
uh the
sqs and ec2 and the elastic cloud
compute but he has they have the
essentials of what is cloud computing
most of us barely understand it we think
it's kind of vaguely interesting it's
like virtualization but weird
but you know it's progress
also in 2006 microsoft recognizing that
they don't understand the web web
developers start making a conference for
web developers
it was called mix which is a great name
this is a great graphic
you notice it looks really nice which
normally you wouldn't get from a 2006
graphic because the original version of
this was 320x200
and i was very frustrated with how bad
it looks on a 1080 screen so i actually
paid a designer to recreate the logo for
me and high-res i have the only
good-looking version of the mix06 logo
you can't have it
but some important things happen at mix
this is where
microsoft finally gets back on the
bandwagon making a new browser ie7 is
announced here and and released and it's
been five years
since ie6 so it had been a long time
they also hinted at a thing
called wpfe but we'll talk about that
later
microsoft's also moving towards open
source by creating their own sourceforge
codeplex this is the graphic i didn't
have recreated okay
see the difference 2006 graphics are not
pretty this one is pretty because i paid
money right this one is not pretty
uh most people remember code if you
remember coldplus from back then you
remember for one thing the ajax toolkit
that was one of the first things that
landed on koplex
and the ajax toolkit i mean talk about
making stuff by accident
so
microsoft started making their own big
mail server
exchange server an exchange server they
wanted to have they've been told to make
web components to make the mail work on
web client not just outlook so they're
working on outlook web access owa
but they really wanted that you've got
mail thing to work and they couldn't
figure out a way to do it so they went
to the ie team and said listen
can you add an ability to basically push
an xml payload back down to the browser
just be an xml request
and that's what you can do when you're a
giant company like that where the guys
are literally down the hall and so
in uh in ie
six they added xml
http requests
no standards no plan no nothing they
just did it so they could go bing when
you got mail in owa that was the point
but that leads to
this whole concept of ajax of this
ability of partially loading pages
so it wasn't anybody's intent it just
was an emergent property of a requested
id that everyone adopted
so starting back with exchange five five
so that's the good news in 2006. let's
talk about the bad news in 2006.
what went wrong
i mean the problem with xp being so
dominant
was that they really had no competitors
at this point they could do anything and
so they tried which was a mistake
the code name for xp was whistler
which is a ski town not far from where i
live in british columbia
and so the next version of windows after
whistler was going to be named for the
mountain beside whistler a mountain
called blackcomb
but this is also when bill gates is now
chief architect and he has entirely too
much time on his hands and so there's a
big push for a 100 object-oriented
operating system well it's like only
something a true believer could
necessarily want and the original
specifications for blackcomb were so
outrageous everybody's like let's dial
that thing back like we got to take a
breath and do something a little simpler
and so they made an interim project
because between the mountain of whistler
and the mountain of black home is a very
large bar
called the longhorn bar
and so in 2004
they announced longhorn which was
the interim project and longhorn went
through some nasty iterations to
eventually become
vista and also generate a new version of
net called.net 3 which was catching all
the stuff that got pushed out of windows
and so by 2007 we've made a little bit
of progress hardware has evolved a bit
you see we've gone beyond the black pc
now you can have red and silver shiny
pcs these are the dell xps it's actually
been a really fun thing for me and
collecting this whole story to look at
how xps is from dell changed
bigger smaller right this is pentium
error that thing you can heat a room
with it like it's
it kicks out a lot of heat it's like
just turn on do turn on quake full reds
you can warm up the room no problem
uh the new the mac is now also on the
intel chipset and again the prettiest
machine made anywhere and the number one
selling phone
is still in nokia
although it's 2007.
so you know it's coming
this thing
it's important to remember that this
phone was not that impressive
this was a 2g phone in a 3g era
and as steve jobs said if you're going
to program for the iphone you're going
to program in safari
because he could see html5 was coming
and he figured that was the way things
were going to go forward he was wrong i
mean hdl5 did show up but hackers are
smarter than he is and they jailbroke
the phone and started making their own
apps
and he was forced to release the
internal tools and create the app store
essentially to manage all of that
and that's why those tools were so bad
because they were coco and xcode they
were only meant to be used internally
they were never meant to be for public
consumption right for developer
consumption
but we're definitely shaking things up
and this is kind of the end of the phone
because before this before the iphone
phones were fun right you could get
keyboards you can get slide out there
are pop-ups there are add-ons after the
iphone all the phones are the same right
it's just a slab of black glass slab of
black glass lava black glass but
it is changing civilization right what
we don't know at that time in 2007 is
every adult human in the world is going
to have one of these ultimately
right that we are all becoming cyborgs
we have digital extensions to ourselves
you know perfectly well you know how
upset you are when you leave the phone
in the bathroom
but that's a very fundamental change to
society right now i mean most time when
you think about cyborgs you think about
implants but a ew
and b
slows down upgrades why would you do
that it's another one to get can't keep
taking it in and out so
it also
tears up software development
because largely for the first time ever
you're the majority of people using your
code
aren't running on the kind of device you
wrote it on
your dev cycle is much more difficult
now and it's
still hard
but previous to the smartphone
revolution we generally worked on the
same kind of machine that the person
consuming our software would run it on
and so your cycle was shorter you could
run it and have a more or less
equivalent experience to what your user
would have
and as phones became dominant that ends
and we struggle
it's hard to build for a different
device
even when you got it tuned the chain is
longer i've got to push that device
evaluate it from there push it back and
then you have the drawer of broken
dreams
right the drawer broken jeans is filled
with smartphones
you start with the most popular
smartphone whatever that phone may be at
the time maybe it's the iphone maybe
it's one of the galaxies whatever it may
be you make your fap look great on that
phone
and then when it looks great on that
phone you go to the drawer broken dreams
and you take out the next phone
and it doesn't look quite right on that
phone
so now you tweak it and tune and make it
look good on that phone now you have to
regress it to the previous phone see how
that looks
and you can get them both working
you go back to the drawer broken dreams
there's a hundred phones in the drawer
broken dreams
so the impact of smartphone development
really shook us up it took a long time
to get better at this and i was argued
we're still on this cycle the historical
starts in 2007. largely we're doing
native development web development will
come a little bit later but we've had
more than a decade of battling this
complex cycle and i think we're getting
better the tooling is improving but it's
a struggle
the first version of silverlight appears
in 2007 as well
now silverlight originally was wpfe or
windows presentation foundation
everywhere
okay
and we did this show on.net rocks
because wpfe was like the worst code
name ever
and brad abrams the guy who's leading
the project time says listen if we have
a cool code name
like avalon
we get a lousy product name like windows
presentation foundation so we're
starting with a bad code name
because then we get a good product name
and if you ever wonder where the word
silverlight comes from i mean the
original version of silverlight in 2007
had nothing to do with net whatsoever it
was it was scripted in javascript and it
was actually made for the media
streaming services for iis so this again
is at the beginning of streaming video
and being able to do variable speed
streaming so reduce resolution to
decrease bandwidth consumption and be
able to stage back up again so you need
a client on the bat on the front end
that can understand what speed we have
available to us and adjust the stream as
necessary this is what netflix depended
on before this netflix shipped out dvds
in red envelopes
after this they start being the
streaming service that became a monster
but there's other parts that are
important to silver light and change the
way microsoft's working as well
the name
silverlight
does exist elsewhere microsoft didn't
invent the word it actually comes from
photography
do you remember those old
instant cameras with the rotating cubes
for taking pictures and every time you'd
fire it it's like a one shot
and then it would rotate and kick again
so that flash process leaves behind
debris
inside of the flash bulb
that's silver light
because silver light is what comes
after flash
and i haven't talked about flash up till
this point because flash is several
years older already right an action
script actually came in 2000 with
beginnings of trying to more
sophisticated scripting
for for the internet right and it leads
to you know great technologies like home
star runner
but
uh silverlight was another approach to
this and of course it will pick up.net
but initially it doesn't have it in
there but mike mike saw
microsoft also wants to get out of band
they're used to making products that
ship with studio
and studio ships every 18 to 24 months
and watching the open source community
iterate rapidly on tools like rails
makes them realize like we're just
moving too slowly so silverlight
initially did never shift in the box in
fact for three years they'll push out
versions
all through codeplex
to be able to rapidly iterate they'll
incorporate net three they'll bring in
mac and bring in max support version of
clr running in the mac all in that short
amount of time and that also on coplex
will be mvc
so mvc again was very much a response to
rails it was an idea of can we get away
from web forms can we build testable
scalable web pages what would that look
like and you may have heard at some
point this apocryphal story of
the nbc being invented by scott guthrie
on the way to a conference it's not true
it's a good story though uh but it was
developed internally and scott guthrie
who led the web team at the time
did reach out to groups of people that
were strong in the open source community
and and you and leveraged nbc as a way
to hire them in fact well i know at
least one of them is here may not be in
the room right now but folks you know we
called them on on drugs we call them
scott guthrie's ninja army
scott hanselman
rob connery phil hack
glenn block all folks with strong open
source backgrounds all got brought in
around mvc
now at the time there was a movement
around microsoft development using more
open source
these
folks were
as a polite term
but they called themselves alt.net
and what they were really presenting was
an idea that open sources should be part
of the net development experience
uh that we made
that a lot of folks were just expecting
microsoft to provide you with everything
you needed you know the normal way to do
development in 2008 2007 was you you
paid for your msdn subscription and you
paid for a control suite
maybe telerik maybe devx maybe component
one like there was a bunch of them but
you pick one
and you're me
and your msd and that's all you use and
so the idea that you would also use open
source was strange at the time and these
were folks that were open source
maintainers and were you know advocating
for that entire movement it's largely
gone away now although it's all come
true
you know open source is a fundamental
part of things but at the time they were
pushing on something that most folks
thought were odd
uh of course that mvc thing turns into a
set of books so there's the the all very
much younger
uh group of troublemakers and they ran
nerd dinners around this
but that's uh that's a beginning of a
cadre inside of microsoft that are very
pro open source
and are trying to do because web
development requires it and they already
recognize that that was an essential
part of the equation
by 2008 we get our first version of
chrome which is kind of amazing when you
think about it
eric schmidt admitted that they stayed
out of the browser wars the squabble
between internet explorer and mozilla
and safari just seemed like something to
stay clear but as it started to calm
down
uh
along came chrome
they'd had they had it around for a few
years internally but we got we got it
publicly in 2008
also the google app engine comes at this
time too this will eventually become the
google cloud product but in 2008 pretty
much announced alongside chrome was hey
if you want to run code on our servers
we can do that for you
right we'll let that uh work and it'll
be in preview for a while they won't
actually call it
google
gcp until 2011. so it's only like a
three year beta i mean faster than gmail
but
you know it was a it was a long
gestation period
by 2008 we're also going after ie6
interestingly enough
uh
dhh the guy behind ruby on rails now
he'd been making and continues doing a
product called basecamp
one of the sort of definitive project
management tools originally email based
and lots of web components way before
most other folks he was very much on the
leading edge of this and he was the one
who wrote in in 2007 he said
in 2008 he says listen i am tired of
making a web page for
browsers and then another one for ie6
so i'm not going to do it anymore
you know if you if you try and go to my
site you're trying to use basecamp with
ie6 i'm really going to tell you go get
a real browser
and it cashes on
like more and then it was a there was a
group of sites in norway there's a bunch
of a bunch of different sites that just
started when you came to that website in
ie6 a box popped up and said listen you
need a real browser
now why was ie6 so evil
well it had the classic combination of
being very popular and not compliant
with standards right they shipped ie6 in
august to 2001. css1 wasn't ratified yet
so they did an implementation of css
based on 0.8
that was different from anything else
so it just misbehaved you literally had
to write if ie 6 code to make this page
behave this sounds very familiar right
it's like safari has become the new ie6
very popular not compliant with
standards and so you end up having to
code for it but then eventually most
microsoft people too start saying listen
like we have ie7 and ie8 you can let ie6
go like it's okay
and you know so it was a very
deliberate active push
to end ie6 it wasn't a simple thing to
do
and so
by 2008 we we fight we get silverlight
now has.net in it and it now becomes
this interesting development tool
where i can now push net code c sharp
code onto a mac and it'll work
inside of a browser
all right it's all plug-in driven
and i'd be remiss not to talk a little
bit about
javascript in 2008
doug crockford who's spoken at this show
in the past
wrote a book called javascript the good
parts it's a really thin book
but what doug was talking about was
look there's a language in here right
this was a scripting tool built to
provide extensibility to browsers but
there's a language in there somewhere we
just got to disentangle it from the dom
and it was an inspiration when you talk
to folks doing
modern
modern tooling for javascript this is
the book that kind of kicks all this off
this javascript needs to grow up
needs to be a real thing because the w3c
is struggling mightily this time
and we're living in dhtml land and it's
not fun and we've spent some time with
xhtml and we know that's a mistake it
turns out not everything tim berners-lee
likes is right
but
this was a sort of an anchoring point
for thinking going forward
uh also in the time period uh ray ozzy
who's taken over for bill gates as chief
architect announces windows azure so
this is microsoft's
cloud response
uh the architect behind it was a guy
named abhishek brilliant brilliant
guy and this is typical of very very
smart people they tend to jump to the
end game so the original
offering from azure
was going to be the web role in the app
role like he basically described
serverless
before any of us wanted it
and so we didn't buy it
but those first few years of azure are
tough but this it gets it gets announced
back at pdc in in you know seven
roughly around the same time we see some
microsystems in big trouble trying to
find financing and ultimately gets
acquired by oracle and i haven't talked
about java at all at this time but you
know java had been around since the 90s
it is it really brought the idea of the
managed run time to modern development
they tried various cloud solutions they
had some interesting choices on how they
did things they wanted to be open source
like they were they definitely had the
pioneer syndrome the idea being the
problem with being a pioneer is you get
arrows in your back
and so the folks that come afterwards
get to learn from your mistakes and and
in some cases outrun you
not that you can argue with the install
base in java
and living in oracle that's a whole
other can of worms and for a few years
it looked pretty bleak although it seems
like the oracle folks have kind of
figured out what it takes to to run a
development environment in a meaningful
way so when i talk to java people these
days they're not that frustrated it's
just like it's a slow big machine but
it's a mature language and a mature
platform that now has multiple languages
running on it
right turns out runtimes can run
anything you want
microsoft finally cleans up their act on
windows windows 7 2009 for better or
worse for many people still the favorite
version of windows
don't tell anybody it's actually you
know vista with some dressing redone on
it they fixed some problems back there
and we do get the the shipped version of
azure doesn't come until 2010 and that
ships with uh sql azure
dotnet
java
and php
that's what the originals have
but we don't remember any of that
because this thing comes out
uh the big iphone
why is it so disruptive
well
on the hardware side we'd been racing
for the 500
laptop for a while
and when you got laptops that cheap they
were terrible
they're all plastic fragile stripped
down barely functional
thick you know ugly machines
and then for eight hundred dollars this
felt little
tablet came along was that was beautiful
and lean and battery life was amazing so
forth so it basically destroyed the
cheap laptop it took that market out
and laptops could would come back but
they'd come back at 1200 or 1500
and so for that you could make a nice
laptop so in some ways this also saved
the laptop but it also put paid to the
m-dots to making separate mobile pages
you know up until now you could get away
with as a developer you built your
regular website or you built your
regular app and then you did something
for the phone
m.yourdomain.com
you're not going to do t dot that's one
too many right we'll do two but three
now it's crazy talk
css media queries had been around in in
the specification now since css1 nobody
took them seriously except audi for some
reason
like if you go to the audi.com site they
can go back into the wayback machine and
you can look in like 2005
the audi.com site is responsive you can
shrink it down it'll reorganize itself
it's astonishing before everybody
audi
but the tablet really now forced us to
all think in terms of you are going to
have multiple form factors the problem
with this device
ctos like it the guy you can't really
say no to you know
i was doing work in i.t back then and
the cto would show up goes i'll be using
this
figure it out
uh
you know it didn't destroy the world
entirely it certainly sent microsoft
into a tailspin
because microsoft now had to focus on
you know how do we respond to this and
this is what will lead to windows 8 for
better or worse
but this is march of 2010
in april of 2010 studio 2010 ships
now this was a marquee version of studio
this was a breakthrough edition this was
all the cleanup from vista done we have
a new version of the runtime we now have
option to compile the 64-bit or the
default is compile any which really
means compile 32 because if you file 64
just means the software doesn't work
we also get f sharp brand new language
in in.net
astonishing fantastic you know thinking
functionally in there
we get silverlight four
so very first original so was 2007
they've now gone through four versions
and got it into the box in less than
three years it runs out of browser
microsoft presents it as their
definitive approach to enterprise
development this is how you should be
building software because it runs on all
the platforms inside of your office it's
going to be great this is what you
should do
also
in the box
jquery
under the mit license so john resig
started it back in 2006.
microsoft working on mvc were using
coplex for it so it's not open source
development the way we think of it today
but what they do is they build
internally a version they call it a
preview they'd push it to coplex we
could download it play with it and then
write comments back about what we liked
what we didn't like
and then they would iterate on that push
new version out sometimes fairly quickly
within a few months
so they got to a point in mvc where they
needed a dom tree navigator as you do
and they start writing their own as
microsoft does
and the community said like what are you
doing this is solved problem just use
jquery
and they did
now in 2010
they put jquery in the box to this day
you can use one of your microsoft tech
support tickets to get support for
jquery
that's strange right but it also
represented this is the company was
moving not only were they building stuff
in their own open source world with
their own coding approaches they're
starting to incorporate others
and so putting jquery in the box to me
seems like an absolute
breakthrough step for microsoft and this
recognition that open source is just a
part of the way we build software now
that it's becoming table stakes it's not
there yet for microsoft it'll be years
but in 2010 they really set an anchor in
the ground
they also
this is right at about this time
is when
steve jobs uh puts out thoughts on flash
it was an open letter
and he said look
flash is bad
well what he was really upset about was
the flash was murdering the battery on
his ipad as it does you could run it on
a different browser and you could see
just the battery you would drain
but it also was the security risk the
the plug-in in general was security risk
and if you were working if you were a
developer back then which means you
provided it to your family you knew
perfectly well every machine that your
family had the address bar had been
replaced by something
right you didn't know what but it was
something right and getting rid of the
plug-in really did stop that
but it's also the death knell for
silverlight
because silverlight depends on a plug-in
nobody's talking about that
that same month
google announces angularjs
they only called angular back then so
angular was an internal project at
google
that people were starting to figure out
existed they were trying to figure out
how some of the ways that gmail and some
of these other google apps worked in the
browser they were astonishing for their
time and so they were looking at the
code inside of the pages thinking how
does this work like what is this
and this was an internal library that
they were using extensively
to the point where goo the team that had
written it mischiek and his and his
voice were in going to the inside of
google saying you should use this and
finally a vp stops them and says listen
if it's really that good why isn't it
available to the public
and so in the fall of 2010 they made a
public version of it
and in this was not the first spa
but this is
this is what kicks single page
applications into high gear that this
idea that the browser is a host for an
app
that still behaves like an app
now
if you went through this time and you
jumped on right now you're about to get
punished in about another year and a
half or so as they figure out oh people
really like this we should change
everything but
you know that's the beginning of all of
this and this multi-form factor whatever
screen resolutions we want to work in we
have to be able to work in
and
yeah by 2013 we're talking about the
year of responsive design
and if you were paying attention to the
silverlight thing at the time that we
said the pdc in 2010
where there were no silverlight sessions
like in april of 2010
silverlight was the marquee product
and then here we are in
october of 2010 and it's not at a
microsoft conference
and a
reporter and friend of mine named mary
jo foley asked the president of server
and tools guy named bob buglia hey
where was silverlight
and he said
our strategy has shifted
and to mj's quote you know credit all
she said she just published what he said
everybody else said silverlight is dead
but and silverlight was well seriously
wounded at that point i mean the reality
was with the thoughts on flash it wasn't
going to run on ios so the cross
platform story was over
but nobody at microsoft had told anybody
externally essentially they knew
internally but they were all locked down
focused on windows 8 at this point and
they were not talking publicly and so we
were kind of left in the dark now the
action at microsoft at the time in by
2011 when this is all happening is in
the browser space
this is when ie9 is in their betas and
they're shipping every few weeks they're
pushing new features out and you can
grab the beta bits over and over again
and firefox is doing the same thing and
so is the chrome team and every time
they come up with a really great feature
they send each other cakes
it was cool there's the coopetition you
know they're all pushing this trying to
push the standards forward this is when
the gpu gets harnessed into html5 and
when we get pre-compilation like
browsers become dramatically faster
now we'll quickly compensate by that by
making web pages way bigger but
you know this actually sets the
foundation for node becoming
proof of javascript living outside of
the browser now node been around for a
few years at this
point but it's in 2011 with the v8
runtime with with google's really fast
java engine the javascript engine that
it makes sense
for to go further with node and to start
thinking about
the other way to do web development
because up until things like node came
along
we were still in that academic internet
world where your
your
back end whether it was iis or apache
was like a swiss army knight with every
blade out everything is on
you know whatever you want to do we can
do right i mean apache is not named for
the for the indian tribe in america it's
literally a patchy server
you download the base runtime and then
you just start loading patches
right like you may have been frustrated
with iis talk to a linux guy about
setting up apache like it's a thing
but it was a philosophical difference it
was this idea of all the services
available with a huge attack surface and
the internet's getting less friendly and
along comes node that says everything is
off i do nothing
now tell me what you want and you've got
a one service at a time stand up the
tooling now eventually we'll build
templates and so forth make it just as
vulnerable as everything else but
initially the mindset of hey why don't
we start with all the blades closed and
just pull out the ones we need
represents some growth and some
evolution
in
taking javascript seriously and the same
for the ecma specifications by 2011
after the battles with the w3c for
trying to figure out what html5 is
really going to be about we get
initially what's called es5 but then
becomes 5.1 and we align
javascript implementations across the
major browsers with the ecmas
specification largely for the first time
ever
again it feels like a moment when we
grew up and said okay we're gonna have a
standard body we're gonna progress
it'll take a few years from here this is
this is like the gathering of folks
saying okay we're going to be nice to
each other it'll be a few years before
they're actually nice to each other
but we're on that pro that on that step
and then
microsoft does the build conference
uh this is the first build it's in 2011
it's in anaheim and it's where they
announce windows 8.
remember i make a show called dot net
rocks so i come out of
i been to pdc in 2010 when there was no
silverlight content and that was
worrying
now i'm at the new developers conference
in 2011 there's no net content
and i say to carl's walking out of the
building you know what if.net doesn't
rock
and we were trying to figure out what to
do with tablet content in general at
that time right how do you talk about
tablet development considering how
diverse it was that's why we made the
tablet show it was sort of our backup
strategy now.net will eventually rock
again
but on that day was not an easy day
now you can understand where microsoft
was at they were trying to respond to
the tablet they thought they saw the
tablet as an existential threat they
were wrong
but they thought that but they also saw
that they needed a lingua franca they
needed to speak the language that was
going to run on all the platforms
and that was going to have to be
javascript and so what they their big
concern now was you couldn't program
windows with javascript so they made
winjs
now look the three guys who use it
thought it was great
okay but
this is they were trying to do a nearly
impossible thing by making something
that is javascript ish
but you know most javascript people
wouldn't even touch it
the roslyn project is underway at this
time although it wasn't publicly visible
it was starting to be talked about what
they did was they pushed it over to
coplex so roslyn was an effort to write
c sharp in c sharp now this is a normal
thing for programming languages to do
it's kind of a metric of you're a mature
language when you can build a compiler
for yourself in yourself i know it's
recursive and weird but that's how
people who make languages think is fun
right that's what they like to do
i'm not a real boy until i've written my
compiler in my own language
but they didn't get to it remember this
language is now 10 years old
and it had been too successful in some
respects but they finally have an
incentive to do and it really came out
of studio 2010 because we had such good
intellisense in studio 2010 that as you
were writing your c sharp card it was
telling you how you were doing it wrong
and the way it did that was with a
real-time compiler essentially that was
watching you write your code and making
sure it was correct which was not the
same compiler as the one you used when
you actually compiled your code that was
a compiler written in c plus plus
and when those two didn't sync up
everybody was unhappy
and so there was this recognition of
it's costing us too much to maintain
these two kinds of compilers we need one
we need a compiler as a service that's
roslyn and it was written in c sharp and
i think the arguably the most important
thing that rosalind did for us
out in the world was make a whole bunch
of c-sharp developers inside of
microsoft
because before rosalind they were all c
plus developers
they still are
but they write a lot of c sharp today
and it's one of the reasons i think c
sharp
had this transformation as as rosalind
came into play and
all of this thinking around c sharp grew
we did shows on this actually we did
them here we were talking to folks like
mads targenstein about i called it the
cambrian explosion of c sharp like this
redesign and the way you're approaching
it allows us to evolve the language way
more efficiently based on people who are
really using it
so that's good news on the dotnet world
at the same time dot net's largely been
ignored by windows because it doesn't
run on the phones
but don't worry
the saint diakaza is coming
miguel
now somewhat older 10 years on he's in
his late 30s at this point
has been quietly working around the mono
project and in fact when the iphone came
out built a cross compiler for mono onto
the iphone he called it mono touch and
by 2011 he's got it running on android
as well
and that's when
novell gets bought by attachmate and
shuts down the mono project
so miguel calls up his friend nat
friedman says we got to give it a home
to this cool project this new you know
building
using c sharp to write mobile apps like
we got to do something and they make a
company called xamarin they ultimately
convince attachment to ship all the
assets to them
that's where xamarin comes from
is that it's the pulling all that stuff
together and focusing on the mobile
development story
it's got problems as you likely know if
you worked on it back then but it's an
extraordinary
goal and i remember at the time saying
hey maybe the person who really believes
in she's sharp this day doesn't work at
microsoft in fact he works at a new
company called xamarin because he was
making c sharp do things that microsoft
said they couldn't do
uh we get the first version of bootstrap
which is a way for all of us web folks
to not think about css anymore
moving on
uh our frigate our friend michael d
our friend anders halsberg that's the
other thing that happened in 2011 as if
2011 or in 2010 wasn't dark enough
that's also when anders steps away from
c sharp now he doesn't really step away
he puts mads in charge he wants to work
on other things and what he's working on
is this
his question was
can we make javascript more reliable
and the whole idea that we had you know
coffeescript was already around like
there were precompilers for for
javascript already he thought he could
make a better one he was right
but more importantly he did the entire
thing on coplex as an open source
project
now there was a firm belief inside of
microsoft at that time that microsoft is
never going to do well in open source as
possible we can do our own thing the
open source community does not like
microsoft they want anything to do with
microsoft and then typescript
because the micros the open source
community loved typescript and all sorts
of contributions came from all kinds of
places because of the way they did the
extensions where you basically didn't
need microsoft permission to write an
extension people wrote extensions
and it was a lightning bolt through
microsoft it says hey when you make good
things that actually help people
the open source community will use them
by 2012 hardware's a little bit sexier
you can see the dell is only large
enough to kill a small animal rather
than a large animal
uh this because at the same time the air
has just come out and now you have a
laptop so thin you can slice cheese with
it
and all the phones look the same
the android galaxy the galaxy is the top
android phone the iphone 5 is the top
iphone phones are now boring
and so microsoft says the only thing
they can do gives themselves a new logo
i mean it's a good this is now the it's
been the logo ever since by 2012 that's
when it happened but microsoft is
transforming at this point right like
they
the forces are at work they create us
wholly owned subsidiary called open tech
and open tech's job is to
uh to make sure that open source
products run on all the dot-net stuff
so and memcached all those things they
have good net clients
and we get
studio 12 2012. most of the version
remember for uppercase menu
which we all hated
we agreed on that
it also supported arm processes which
was kind of important but we don't think
a lot about that and by build 2012 we
have win 8 we have studio 2012 and the
vast majority of the apps for win8 are
written in c sharp and xaml so so much
for win js
all right i'm gonna go through the last
of this quickly because now we're
getting into modern times i hope you had
fun with the that first decade because a
lot of people don't know it because
there are amazing transformative things
that happen after this when it's going
to go away we're going to focus on the
new microsoft that's going to transform
by 2014.
ai has the one of the most significant
breakthroughs the modern breakthrough in
2012.
this guy named jeffrey hinton out of the
university of toronto who'd been
involved in ai from way before it was
sexy going back to the 70s and 80s done
all the original neural net stuff and
he'd written these papers about back
propagation and said the computing just
can't handle it well in 2011 his
graduate students grab onto that
technology start working on it and they
put it into the image
the imagenet recognition challenge so
this has been running for a few years
which was 14 million identified images
so said what was on them and they were
using decision trees and they were
getting about 70
success rate the first attempt by
hinton's team in 2012 using the
the
adversarial neural nets 95
the next year it's 100
this is the ai revolution
this is when it happens
uh the beginning of it all of the other
stuff you see from here
comes from that this new neural net
model using gpus
docker comes out with containers
containers been around for years right
now they will come up with a standard
based on linux that will take over the
market and they'll never make a penny on
it that's a shame
uh react comes down from facebook from
the facebook folks at jsconf as another
spa views will fall shortly after this
is sort of the consolidation of web
development in the different spa
frameworks which is very powerful and
then in 2014 we have the revolution of
microsoft this is when satya nadella is
now
the the ceo
they opened the show at the keynote by
saying if you want to run windows on a
device with a screen nine inches smaller
windows is free
right they've had 30 years of windows as
the center of the company and they open
their new show with windows is free for
small form factors because they're
becoming a cloud company that's what
their focus is and you can tell because
they rename azure from windows azure to
microsoft azure
they're now
their goal is to sell compute which
means they don't care what operating
system runs they want you to run on
anything whatever you want to run on
it's good enough for them
html the html specification finally gets
ratified and it is awesome
the android or the amazon echo comes out
because we were not being spied on
enough
uh
this is also voice recognition you never
trained this device
it worked with anybody's voice unless
you were australian
but everybody else it was fine but it
was just you know again part of this
evolution of ai technologies microsoft
makes their next hit in the open source
space with visual studio code
this time they believe they could do it
can we make the best editor
and within five years it will be the
number one editor but they went in with
that intent what does the world need
from an editor what can we take from
what we've learned in our window-centric
world that can be applied to everyone
that's visual studio code
they also put on edge so not everything
they do is brilliant
but they'll fix it eventually and we get
the progressive web app
so this was a specification from the
google guys and it was really how do we
extend
the spa into be more appalite with a
manifest and different rules it hasn't
gone necessarily where it wanted to go
but it's an interesting part of the
progression uh
aqua specification six which they
quickly renamed to 2015 because numbers
are hard
uh but i but i mean this is when they're
now on the track by 2015 we've had a
version of ecma every year
it's still we still have to wait for the
browser to implement it but largely the
browser
folks are on those teams and they're
helping to decide new features we have a
growing and evolving language
we need to manage our containers and we
come up with kubernetes why did
kubernetes win because for a while there
there were lots of orchestrators
this is one that was built by brennan
burns working for google
which is fine it was open source it had
its features it had strengths and
weaknesses but then brendan burns goes
to microsoft in 2016
and now microsoft quickly does an
implementation of kubernetes that runs
on azure well the aks
and amazon looks out and goes holy cow
and they do an implementation as well
and now there's one orchestration engine
that runs on all three of the big cloud
platforms and on premises and so in a
way we create a monopoly
that doesn't seem to be quite as toxic
as most monopolies right kubernetes has
essentially dominated the space for
better or worse it's still an open
source project that has contributors
from multiple places all the major
platforms run it and you can run it
yourself it's now because it's gotten as
large as this has a decent ecosystem
around it with tools like helm and a
host of others
this is i think is a very significant
innovation for development that we can
agree on one way to do things something
more or less one set of tools if we do
it in an open way
and we do it in a way where nobody no
one vendor has control over it no
pricing on it that being said
did google take away
brendon's check-in rights when he went
over to microsoft like now there's an
interesting game between these check
giants for who owns those repositories
you know because now microsoft's going
to start implementing
is implementing chromium like how those
contributions working microsoft does
eventually by xamarin in 2016 we did
shows around that and miguel and nat
join microsoft um that will go on to
become the ceo of github when they
acquire that
and microsoft decides to completely
rewrite net
because they wanted an open source
cross-platform cloud-centric version of
net and net up until now had been built
to run on windows and disentangling it
from that was impossible it was easier
to start over which is a straw
extraordinary if you think about it you
know at this point it's 15 years old
and they're going to start over
and steve sanders is around here
somewhere but at the ndc conference in
oslo back in 2017
he took an open source version of
c-sharp
rammed it through that could compile
through
ltd lttm into web assembly and showed us
what would eventually become blazer and
blew all our minds
um
that's got a lot of evolving to go but
you know it's extraordinary what it
represented at the time and it's still
moving that way
by 2017 hardware is generally looking
sexy now i mean the clean silver box it
is a tower pc
uh the ipad the imac is run out of ideas
so now it used to be silver now it's
black
but it has 32 cores because that's a
good idea and yeah and you can now get
an iphone in rose gold
that's the evolution of civilization
right there uh codeplex becomes an
archive in 2017 because microsoft has
moved everything to github and github
will be their central focus
ultimately culminating them owning
github because they need to their whole
company runs on it for better or worse
but i'll throw in some a little more ai
conversation you remember alphago
so back in the 90s ibm with deep blue
beat chess with a decision tree engine
but go was considered impossible for a
decision tree engine
and so the group at deepmind spent a
couple of years building a neural net
model to play go and by 2017 it beat the
best go player in the world that was
alphago they then in the same year
re-engineered it into a self-training
model called alpha zero
so rather than having it look at games
and how games were played just know the
rules and play yourself
so it took them two years to train the
original model
alpha zero trained to beat alphago in 30
days
microsoft acquires github
for the most part nobody minds
just means they don't have to make money
anymore all we really notice is we paid
less
dot net core grows up
the version three is the point where
they start making sdks for ux libraries
is when we get winforms into.net core
it's just a different version of
winforms you have to make some changes
to move across to it but it's compelling
uh cro the edge browser gets fixed by
running the chromium engine which is an
interesting loop
that now microsoft's contributing to an
open source library for their
competitors browsers they're using in
their own browser it's fun to see them
fight back and forth in that one there
is some oddities going on there but for
us in the developing space you know
we're witnessing all of that
and we're down to almost current times
now gbd3
this generative pre-trained transformer
basically ability to read and understand
text and do stuff with it and if you
play with it at all you've seen things
like the open ai codex where i can
basically describe a game
and with through gpd3 it'll turn that
into code for me but i would talk about
i think the single most impactful thing
that's happened it comes from those deep
mind folks it's alpha fold too i don't
know if you've followed this so you
remember the same initiative i talked
about with them with imagenet and how
they took 14 million images and made it
back a recognizer for it
so
protein folding is one of the most
complex aspects of of
biological science going on right now we
barely understand it ourselves
and the folks at deepmind have now taken
the models that played go and applied it
to protein folding and just last year or
the
alpha fold 2 was able to recognize
protein folding formats more advanced
than anything we'd figured out ourselves
most of the time with ai models machine
learning models they're doing things we
could do ourselves that just they'll do
it automatically and cheaply
this is one of the very few examples
we've had so far of it's doing something
we can't do
it's getting a 90 accuracy of
recognizing behavior and protein folds
that have never been shown before
they're still struggling to validate all
of the data it's produced
but this is a step
forward in how ai models can work to
solve effectively what we're now seeing
is unsolvable problems
the cloud is a very vital part of that
it takes a huge amount of compute to
build these models not that much to run
it so it makes sense to have cloud to be
able to harness all that compute run the
model and and try it but we're starting
to solve uniquely complex problems with
this technology
and then we also have github copilot
because microsoft's taken everything
that's in github that's probably visible
and fed it through that same engine and
now if you play with this and you start
writing code it's going to take what
your code looks like and help finish it
for you based on what others have done
on github even if it's a bad idea
but
that's where that comes from right this
is that same model gpt3
and just having access to term events
about the data whether that image data
whether that's protein folding data or
that's code
we take these models and we apply to
them and we can amplify them it's just a
tool for us and it gives us ability to
write code faster hopefully it'll
actually be useful but eventually we'll
just call it intellicode
right now it's copilot
and
last year we got dotnet six kind of the
consolidating versions of dotnet
dotnet seven comes in this november
they're on an annual cadence now six
will be the is the long-term support
version which these days means three
years
because it's in our best interest to
keep our code compilable one way or the
other it's how we've evolved that's what
20 years has done for us
i don't know what's next all i know is
i've been really enjoying the ride and i
hope you have too
have a great day thank you so much for
coming
you